[Musique]
septembre 2019
naples italie le stress est à son comble
au napoli pizza au village le grand
championnat international de la pizza on
était six cent soixante à participer
c'est compétition sur trois jours c'est
une vraiment intense dans la catégorie
out aliot voici la pizza gagnante c'est
la meilleure pizza les 2019
c'est la meilleure au monde il faut
goûter
le créateur de cette pizza mirko
d'agatha c'est à gauche et à droite
ben c'est ça la présente après même ma
carrière et mes origines du nord
l'italie c'est la place où je suis né
ses tourelles au nom de la libye mais
paris bien de la sicile d'un client il
ya un peu douce ou d'italie un peu dur
en italie mélanger ensemble cette pizza
composé de tomates de mozzarella di
buffala fumée de noisettes rottiers de
pancetta mirko là bien sûr fièrement
inscrits à son menu chez morceau qu'est
ce que vous pensez que séduit les juges
dans sa brawn aller voter vous même les
côté croustillant au sud sur le même
serveur
c'est ça qui selon les juges y adonner
les petits plus à la pizza
la pizza al taglio qu'on appelle aussi
pizza à la coupe ou à la romaine est la
nouvelle coqueluche ses dires des
médecins là il est évidemment à rome à
fin des années 60 cet événement
initialement un pays tiers qui ont mangé
dans les boulangers n'existait pas
vraiment défi céréales taille ou de
suite altaï parce que c'est à la coupe
donc on la poupée minutes puis on a pesé
sur la balance et on l'a payé au kilo
évidemment qui en été ça fonctionne
encore comme ça la personnalité de ce
type de pizzas se résume en une pâte
normand fermenté et des garnitures st on
a tout le temps la partie se verrait à
l'amp est plus moelleuse et la partie
inférieure car quand c'est particulier
en bouche c'est surprenant les premiers
fois qu'on en mange pour parvenir à
cette texture ça prend un mélange de
farine et beaucoup de coûts sur l'ebita
normale sur les kilos de farine ya 600
grammes d'eau ici sur les kilos de
fruits à 850 grando vraiment c'est très
hydratant il ya un fermentation très
long au frigo avec les 72 96 heures
après ça on les baisse sur la sueur de
la farine des émules on a fait
travailler pour garder leur agression la
main au four environ à 300 sessions
environ 600 fahrenheit disons pendants
entre 10 et 13 14 minutes après ça on
l'a fait reposer en a mais seul un gris
pour perdre l'humidité la chaleur et on
redonne 1 2
puis sont toutes deux cuissons il ya
depuis son camp les clients il a cherché
ça c'est la troisième petit frisson de
six élèves ont mal à réchauffer à chaque
fois qu'on a des chances qu'on perde en
paix de militaires mais on gagne 1
réhabiliter un quotient ça c'est son
parti qui est à la fois légères un peu
humide mais craque en écolo qu'abrite
fabrizio cobourne et est également un
pizzaïolo devenait de montréal
dirigeants avec sa famille les restos
bottega et sans jonah hill porte lui
aussi une attention particulière à sa
part car contrairement à ce qu'on dit
le secret n'est pas toujours dans la
sauce où vous avez inspiré de les trois
stages que j'ai fait avec les 3 mètres 1
c'était là gabriel et banshee qui
l'autre ses terres locales
alors cette recette à base de trois
types de farines aussi un seul qui donne
un goût de noisette la simone et à rob
lowe qui en a le nom blanche et au sein
fabrizio préfère ne faire qu'une seule
cuisson et pour les garnitures pas plus
de trois ingrédients
ça c'est ce sauce tomate ou celui de
livres à la fin peu d'origan pts 2
vasella et moi j'aime ajoutent les mêmes
les vêtements de ses réseaux si ça donne
une autre profondeur honda le goût un
anneau ça c'est vraiment délicieux déjà
la source thomas qu'on sent que c'est
une recette familiale où je pense que
c'est même pas nous on utilise internet
qui vient d'italie et on ajouter rien du
tout on fait écraser à main passée dans
une passoire
si on ajoute un peu de salles seulement
pour les deux pizzaïolo d'origine
italienne vous le diront la classique
des pizzas romaine et l'étonnant pizza
aux pommes de terre très bon c'est doux
c'est une explosion de saveurs tellement
simplement conscient et la pomme de
terre et il nous donne l'humidité qu'on
a des besoins avec les quotients c'est
quelque chose moi c'est vraiment manger
sur le pouce
la pizza romaine se conserve bien au
frais quelques jours beaucoup de clients
ils pensent que c'est costaud et fois qu
on la mange c'est tellement aérienne
thème en léger repli conscient que mon
on oublie tout de suite
tout de suite elle à la cat et au ping
call en perdition
[Musique]